harvest season is begun in California's
Napa Valley but the 160 billion dollar
wine industry could dry up if something
isn't done to combat a changing climate
Jamie yuccas travelled there to find out
what options are available Jamie what
can you tell us well Michelle is a grape
ripens the compounds within it perform a
delicate shifting balancing act for the
right taste texture and color so any
shift in climate conditions can be
detrimental to the vines while a red
wine should be aged in barrels
these Cabernet grapes are dying on the
vine
Andy Beck Stouffer has been growing
grapes for some of the biggest names in
California wine country since the early
1970s
how much cab do you drink a day
breakfast lunch or dinner but he's
concerned about his future harvest the
big deal is the erratic nature that we
have with climate here we have bugs we
never heard of we have diseases we never
heard of before we have we've changed
the way we farm because of it you're
fighting against climate change yes here
in Napa Valley cab is king it's also
where researchers are trying to save it
with 11 different projects happening all
over the area you want to keep the wine
quality that's right we want to keep it
delicious and cost worthy of that $300
bottle Beck Stauffer vineyards is
investing tens of millions of dollars
partnering with UC Davis for the world's
most ambitious Cabernet Sauvignon root
stock and clone trial vineyard manager
Clint Nelson and researcher Concord Hall
say the area has heated up by nearly two
degrees a year it may not sound like
much but viticultural is say it's enough
to eventually make Cabernet grapes
extinct we cannot just say like oh I
will start thinking about it 20 or 30
years from now you know you have to you
know take action now what does it mean
to this area that you're doing this
research we don't look at this as just a
northern California trial or experiment
we look at this as an industry-wide
trial UC Davis is using shade Nets
switching from horizontal
two vertical planning and various
technology to grow a better stronger
grape you have naysayers they might
think we're going too far
spending too much money doing it with
chasing things that won't turn up
researchers are testing a hundred
combinations but it will take at least
six years to yield results like any fine
wine Beck Stauffer says it will take
time but the fate of one of America's
most famous valleys may hang in the
balance
we'll use that data not only to fight
climate change but in the best but
hopefully to improve the wine quality
that's the big deal and this is a really
big deal for Napa 65% of the grapes that
are grown there are Cabernet Sauvignon
so this is going to have a major impact
this is an impact as far as climate
change on everything we were working on
a story with coffee same thing and UC
Davis and on the research with that as
well heating up yeah